that's me right there okay honey don't  we knew at the end of season four that  we had posed a question how was killer  frost really created and for what  purpose  that leads directly into the story of  what's really wrong with Kaitlyn are  family issues and that's all what season  five is about it's about thinking my mom  is a billet that's why you're here isn't  it this is some elaborate possibly  nefarious cover-up it must be mom's  doing it's not like she's ever had your  best interests at heart you always do  this well your mom's not a villain it's  about thinking my dad he's a great human  being  newsflash your dad is bad what did you  do to me  I wasn't gonna let the ALS manifesting  you like it didn't mean so you used  experiments with cryogenic gene therapy  on your own daughter I already done it  on myself  really bad  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]